my daddy cans over two years so for a
good like six I could say six monthly
bless kind of six months to maybe even a
year like we were we're taking a flight
a week I just felt like if I wasn't in
like caretaker mode or filming mode then
I was doing something wrong the Dolan
twins announced they're taking a step
back from making weekly YouTube videos
unfortunately the times that we've taken
breaks from the weekly uploads
everyone's been but I do feel like I'm
letting people down nineteen-year-old
twins
Ethan and Grayson made the announcement
on their YouTube channel Tuesday posting
an hour-long video that explained their
decision after their father died in
January following a two-year long battle
against cancer
they said they were forced to re-examine
their lives and careers I was like
filming or like acting like I was happy
around my dad like just like crazy like
having fun was like the biggest guilt
trip ever the twins also opened up about
the aftermath of their dad's death
admitting that they wished they could
have spent more time with family had it
not been for their demanding filming
schedule had we not been filming the
video every week like we would have been
able to spend like more time with their
family the twins also shared their plans
for the future telling fans that they're
going to focus on making videos they're
passionate about they said their dad
will forever be their biggest
inspiration every kid growing up really
wants to be the man after they're dead
and that's what we want to do that's
definitely what keeps us going and I
think that's kind of our answer for why
we haven't stopped
[Music]
you
[Music]